dans le cadre de l'événement au bonheur
des enfants organisé par le département
le public a pu observer deux nouvelles
résidentes plutôt exotiques il s'agit de
deux tortues terrestres en provenance
des Séchelles appelé plus communément
tortu géante les visiteurs du parc ont
ainsi eu le privilège et l'honneur de
pouvoir les observer de près alors
bonjour je m'appelle Adrien et je suis
le guide du jardin l'état donc
aujourd'hui on va vous présenter les
tortues donc qui sont présents dans dans
le jardin pour le bonheur des enfants
alors elles ont quel âge sorti donc la
plus grosse elle a 60 ans donc elle est
assez âgée et la deuxème elle est encore
un peu jeune donc elle a 35 ans cette
tortue terrestre est la plus grosse
connue puisqu'elle peut atteindre 1 m
pour 300 kg les femelles sont un peu
plus petites mesurant en moyenne 90 cm
leur longévité peut ainsi dépasser les
ans j'aime ça je trouve qu'elles sont
joli leur
carapace c'est comme ça c'est plus pour
montrer aux enfants les plus jeunes quoi
quo donc voilà d'accord et niveau des
tortures vous en avez chez vous non non
du tout et là vous vous êtes
impressionné com vu par la taille des
tortues la grosseur des tortues ouais
c'est c'est impressionnant on a
l'habitude de voir les petites les
moyennes mais les grosses comme ça c'est
rare quoi et bon c'est un animal très
domestique très gentil il y a 40 ans ces
tortu était déjà installé au jardin de
l'État acheté récemment par le
Département aux EAU il est prévu que
cette tortue s'y réinstalle
définitivement courant 2016 pour le plus
grand bonheur des grands mais également
des T petits